Hello, it's Dr. Kevin Conner's again, a new look of cancer session 12 talking about my favorite things
Oh, this is a fun one today because this is another one of my favorite things and that is
Curcumin you might have heard of curcumin. It's turmeric. It's the active form of turmeric the spice turmeric that you can buy in the health
food store or buy in your
local co-op to put into Indian dishes. You might find it in curry
It is a great thing to use buy it use it get it in your body any way you can get it in your body
If you have cancer, it is a wonderful tool
So you just look at this chart. It's a wonderful chart that centerpiece it helps with people that have an over-expression of
Unca genes so we spoke about unca genes those are genes that promote cancer growth
You've seen her too. Those are estrogen receptive positive breast cancers and ovarian cancers and uterine cancers
Hormone positive
cancers the reason why there's such a
Nasty thing to have is because you have all these extra receptors on the cell membrane that
Increase cell reproduction. Well, it only works if the bad esters is attached to those receptors and cuba did
Curcumin
Help dislodge those bad estergins from those receptors. So it's just a fantastic tool for that it decreases growth factors
It affects the growth factor receptors. So it's going to decrease cell reproduction
It's going to decrease survival factors that cancers have and
It is just a wonderful tool to decrease inflammation
We didn't talk about matrix methanol protease. It's the optimal. We're going to get to that in a later presentation
but it helps with with
with that process and
Just so many positive benefits of curcumin we could go on and on
On the right of this slide. I love it because this talks about how different drugs target different things like the Cox two pathways the paid pathway
The her two pathway is the estrogen-receptive pathway and they have a drug
Herceptive that is supposed to work so well for that well herceptive has a bunch of different side effects to it
And in real life it actually works much poorer than it does in any of their studies
Because the handpicked those studies and used only the ones to get the drug past
That showed positive results and they just ignore the ones that didn't
truth sorry
and
Like a vast it is supposed to block Vaget production Vaget production member is the vascular endothelial growth factor where
Cancer starts to stimulate this endothelial growth factor, so it'll stimulate growth of
vascular tissue into its
It's mass, so it could get a blood supply and get a a glucose supply, so it could continue to grow because
How can cancer continue to grow if it doesn't have the ability to get its nutrients?
So cancer feeds on glucose and where is it going to get its glucose?
Well it gets its glucose from your blood supply
So if it can stimulate an increased blood supply into itself, it's going to be able to get glucose and
Increase its reproduction. Well, a vast it was as a drug created that was meant to stop Vaget production
It doesn't do it as well again
Curcumin does this curcumin attacks all these all these things. It's so multi-targeted on the on the left-hand side
It decreases inflammatory cytokines it decreases
Insights that increase cancer growth and could cause
Cancer's in themselves because it the certain enzymes can affect the DNA telemiers it
It affects growth factors, so growth factors that increase the cell rep reproduction
Curcumin affects those in a positive way. It down regulates receptors that are
receptors for
Increase multiplication and it up
Regulates receptors that stimulate apoptosis. I mean it's like a miracle drug. It's absolutely a miracle drug. It affects adhesion molecules
Never we talked about collected three was one of those adhesion molecules that
Causes the cancer cells to kind of bind together. So they bind together and they could kind of team up
So if there's multiple cancer cells bond together, they have a better ability to to ward off
Response with the macrophage because it's getting too big for the macrophage to surround and kill
Well
Curcumin breaks that bondage of those adhesion molecules
So it breaks up the cancer so the immune system can get in between the cells and start to destroy the cancer
It is just
It's a wonderful, wonderful drug if we want to call it a drug because it really acts so wonderful
We could call it that now that there's
There's some issues at how we want to take this so we'll talk about that in a second. So
It has been shown to affect literally every type of cancer in a positive way
There just isn't anything bad about curcumin the studies are coming in a lot of studies on curcumin are coming in
So there's nothing bad about curcumin except what I'm gonna tell you so the only thing bad about for curcumin is that
If you spill it on you, it will stay in your clothes and you will not get it out no better what you do
So that's the only thing bad about curcumin. Well, who cares? You're swallowing this stuff. Well, that's not always true
So with skin cancers and
Rashes and things like that. We make our own specific curcumin creams that we want people to put on there on their body
And then it gets a little difficult because you have to put a bandaid over there or something over to cover it up because it'll state everything your sheets and everything
However, that's the only thing bad about curcumin. It has no side effects whatsoever
It is insane not to be taking that if you have cancer or any sort of inflammation processes
It's not a TH1 stimulator. It's not a TH2 stimulator
So if you have an autoimmune disease curcumin is always safe
So here's some little caveats about taking curcumin. Oh, I was gonna put a slide into the curcumin
We use we use a designs for health. It's called C3 curcumin. I didn't put that in on this
You can find it in our store
And the reason why I like it is it's pre-abose to find it a fat
So that's rule number one to take a curcumin. Why?
I feel not in this slide presentation. I didn't even put in my rules
Rule number one to take a curcumin is you got to take it with a fat
So you have to take it with a fat. So if you take curcumin
If you go down to your natural food store where you buy all your great
Organic vegetables you can buy a bag of turmeric. So you can take turmeric and
percentage of that turmeric is gonna be curcumin
So how much of that turmeric should you take on a daily basis?
Well, you should probably take up to
You know several teaspoons a day of that turmeric would be a great dosage to start on your turmeric
However, it's taste horrible
So unless you're from India and you've developed the taste for that kind of stuff most Americans don't think turmeric tastes very good
So you're gonna want to capsilize it so it gets really messy if you're gonna capsilize it yourself
Your skin turns yellow and all sorts of stuff because it's that yellow
Curry spices what it is
So if you buy it at capsules you want to take a
Fairly high dose most turmeric capsules come in a dosage of 400 to 500 milligrams on the average
So you want to take upwards to
2,000 to 8,000 milligrams of turmeric
Have specific type of cancers you may even want to take higher doses of that
But you have to take it with a fat
So if you take it with a capsule and it's not pre-emulsified in a fat like designs for health product is
Then you can take it with a little bit of coconut oil. So it's really simple
Take three capsules take a little take a
Teaspoon or a tablespoon of coconut oil and you're good to go
A lot of the studies that came out into a number of years ago
Showed that it worked in real life with people were getting it in their food
But it didn't work nearly as well with people were taking capsules till they figured out it was the delivery system
It needs fat to get across the gut wall
So you just don't absorb it well without a fat
So you want to add a fat to your diet. Now you could certainly take the capsules
Right with your meal if you're going to eat a meal that contains a decent amount of fat
You're fine to do it that way too. So I have a lot of patients that do that
The other thing that helps the absorption it helps the half life of turmeric in your body
It also does so with the resveratrol in your body side note is
Taking a little black pepper with it
So black pepper the constitute a black pepper works really well to help increase the half life of turmeric and resveratrol
Agree to extract actually and it helps the absorption of it
So you got to take it with a fat and a little bit of black pepper and you're going to be good to go
Very anti-inflammatory if you have joint issues autoimmune issues with
inflammatory joints painful joints
Lyme patients, chronic Lyme patients do really well on high dose turmeric as well as autoimmune patients and any cancer patients
It's a wonderful pain reliever too because it blocks cox tube pathways
And it partly relieves the pain because it blocks the inflammation pathways
So as a decrease in inflammation, that's where most your pain comes from
So turmeric is a great product. I love it. We use it all the time with patients
All right, we'll get done to the next one next week. I hope you enjoyed it. Bye